رغم الكثير من رواه من ردود الفعل
الايجابيه لتشات جي بي تي الا ان البعض
يجادل انه ليس مثاليا كما يبدو ويشككون في
قدرته على التحقق من دقه الاخبار شات جي
بي تي لا يزال قيد التطوير ولا يملك
معلومات كافيه لما بعد 2000 21 وهو العام
الذي تم فيه تغذيته بالبيانات الشركه
المطوره اوبن اي اي شات جي بي تي نبهت
المستخدمين من انه قد يقدم اجابات خاطئه
وقد يتبادل الردود العنصريه والاخطر انه
يقدم اجابات تبدو منطقيه لكنها ليست الا
محضه
الشركه تؤكد على ان المشروع لا يزال في
بدايته ترغب في معرفه اراء المستخدمين
وتقيماتهم لكي تتمكن من تحسينه وتطويله
ربما هذه هي الاسباب التي تجعل جوجل
مترددا تاجيل اطلاق روبوت محادثاته الذكي
لندن على نطاق الواسع رغم الاعلان عنه منذ
نحو عامين خوفا من هامش الخطا المرتفع
الذي قد يضره بسمعه الشركه